bonsoir et bienvenue ça vous regarde en
direct notre grand témoin ce soir c'est
le politologue Dominique réduit bonsoir
directeur de la Fonda Paul la Fondation
pour l'innovation politique qui publie
ce week-end une étude passionnante sur
les liens entre la crise médiatique et
la crise démocratique que connaît notre
pays depuis bien longtemps on va en
parler vous allez nous la révéler
d'ailleurs en exclusivité ce soir les
réseaux sociaux sources d'un
bouleversement de l'information qui ont
aussi des choix des conséquences sur le
choix des électeurs c'est passionnant on
en parle longuement tout à l'heure mais
on commence bien sûr avec l'interview
d'Emmanuel Macron le chef de l'État est
donc sorti du silence après le 49-3 sur
les retraites il assume tout et veut
avancer sur les réformes pas
nécessairement par la loi mensonge déni
mépris les réactions des oppositions
sont extrêmement vives ce soir les
syndicats promettent une mobilisation
record demain dans la rouille Macron
droit dans ses bottes c'est notre grand
débat dans un instant avec nos invités à
vous de retrouver à 20h15 les parties
pris de nos affranchis et puis Bourbon
Express bien sûr l'histoire du jour à
l'Assemblée vous me suivez Dominique
renier ça vous regarde c'est parti
[Musique]
alors a-t-il convaincu ou au contraire
a-t-il jeté de l'huile sur le feu il est
en tout cas sorti de son silence à la
veille d'une nouvelle journée d'action
qui s'annonce massive et au lendemain
d'une motion de censure rejetée de
justesse à l'Assemblée 4 députés sur ce
plateau ce soir pour revenir sur
l'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron Charles
Simpson et bienvenue vous êtes député
renaissance du Bas-Rhin bonsoir Michel
Tabarro bonsoir ravi de vous retrouver
député les républicains des
Alpes-Maritimes sur la ligne Ciotti
maintenant faut préciser un Pradier
ciotique je précise donc que vous n'avez
pas voté la censure bonsoir Kevin ma
vieux bienvenue député rassemblement
national de l'Eure enfin bienvenue à
vous Stéphane peu député communiste bien
sûr de Seine-Saint-Denis et membre de la
nuque merci à tous les quatre de
participer à ce débat en direct de mini
crémier évidemment le politologue que
vous êtes un regard sur cette
intervention présidentielle et on a
envie de l'entendre n'hésitez pas à
intervenir quand vous le souhaitez alors
on commence sur les temps forts de cette
interview que retenir des 30 minutes
d'intervention d'Emmanuel Macron il a
deux secondes pour nous les résumer
c'est le chrono de Blacko pour commencer
et je me retourne comme chaque soir pour
vous accueillir du haut de votre estrade
Stéphane bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et
tous il est sorti du silence ça y est et
oui à la veille de cette grande journée
de mobilisation prévenue pour demain
alors que des blocages des débordements
qui prennent de l'ampleur le président
ce midi m'a exprimé qu'un seul regret
celui de ne pas avoir réussi à
convaincre les Français de la nécessité
de cette réforme des retraites
d'ailleurs même si le texte est adopté
oui il a quand même essayé de faire
encore un petit coup de pédagogie en
amenant son carton pour rappeler que oui
regardez si on se compare les Français
partent plutôt à la retraite que dans la
plupart des pays européens mais là on a
bien vu que le président s'occupait de
tout tout seul c'est que non seulement
il amène ses propres cartons mais que
pour l'interview il fait et les
questions et les réponses on l'écoute
au moment où je vous parle est-ce que
vous pensez que ça me fait plaisir de
faire cette réforme dites-le nous non
est-ce que vous pensez que j'aurais pas
pu faire comme tente avant moi mettre la
poussière sous le tapis oui peut-être
donc cette réforme elle est nécessaire
et je le dis aux Français ça ne me fait
pas plaisir j'aurais voulu ne pas la
faire mais c'est pour ça aussi que j'ai
pris l'engagement de l'affaire devant
vous par le sens des responsabilités
cela dit je vous rassure le président
n'est pas non plus complètement sourd
vous savez que les pires sourds sont
ceux qui refusent d'entendre or lui il a
bien entendu que le principal reproche
qu'on faisait sa réforme c'est d'être
injuste du coup il a sorti du chapeau un
argument qui à mon avis pour être
utile pour les ministres les députés de
la majorité lorsqu'il rencontre des
Français qui leur reprochent que tous
les efforts pèsent en ce moment sur les
travailleurs en écoute la solution
imaginée par le président
il y a quand même un peu un cynisme à
l'oeuvre quand on a des grandes
entreprises qui font des revenus
tellement exceptionnels qu'ils en
arrivent à utiliser cet argent pour
racheter leur propre action là je vais
demander au gouvernement de pouvoir
travailler à une contribution
exceptionnelle pour que cet argent quand
il y a des profits exceptionnels
d'entreprises qui sont très racheteurs
propres actions que leur travailleur
puisse en profiter donc comme
renseignant vite fait j'ai appris qu'il
y avait eu 24 milliards d'actions
rachetés l'année dernière au 4-40 donc
la question c'est de savoir quelle sera
la part de la contribution mais puisque
le président reconnaissait les
injustices il y en a une autre qui l'a
reconnu et elle concerne les métiers
pénibles c'est un peu une surprise parce
qu'il a admis que oui effectivement
quand on était éboueur on ne pouvait pas
rester éboueur jusqu'à 64 ans sauf que
pour lui la solution c'est pas que les
métiers pénibles partent plutôt à la
retraite la solution serait qu'il y ait
des reconversions qui soient organisées
quand on arrive dans l'âge de la
cinquantaine par exemple alors l'idée
paraît pas mauvaise mais simplement pour
ça il faudrait quand même s'entendre
avec les partenaires soci aux donc les
syndicats en ce moment demain en
l'occurrence tous les syndicats
extrêmement leur désaccord avec le
président dans la rue donc apparemment
le président lui a bon espoir de
reprendre que le syndicats auront la
main tendu on écoute moi je souhaite
il faut attendre quelques jours quelques
semaines mais qu'on réengage avec les
partenaires sociaux sur des sujets très
concrets l'usure professionnelle la
reconversion de fin de carrière il y a
beaucoup de métiers ou au font passer 50
ans de reconverti vous voyez il a encore
des projets de réforme donc sans qu'on
obsession c'est de ne surtout pas c'est
des à l'immobilisme or depuis le début
de ce nouveau quinquennat qu'est-ce qui
ralentit le plus l'action réformatrice
du président de son gouvernement c'est
bien sûr le fait qu'il n'est pas la
majorité absolue à l'Assemblée alors il
s'agit pas de se passer du Parlement
évidemment mais enfin il a prévenu qu'il
avait des confié à Elisa une bande le
soin de mettre au point une nouvelle
méthode pour mener les nouvelles
réformes en écoute
bâtir un programme législatif et un
programme de gouvernement en lien avec
le président de l'Assemblée et la
présidente la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale et le président du Sénat que
j'ai vu hier pour avoir la foi moins de
textes de loi des textes plus courts
plus clairs
il faut agir au service de nos priorités
de nos compatriotes le faire de manière
très concrète avec les élus sur le
terrain avec les services de l'État et
tout ne passe pas par la loi et on passe
trop par la loi dans notre République
c'est pas le premier non plus le
Président on va dire qu'on vote trop de
loi en France enfin dans ce contexte on
a quand même le sentiment que il
voudrait pouvoir réduire un peu le rôle
du Parlement pour laisser les mains plus
libres à l'exécutif j'imagine que vous
êtes député que vous allez réagir à ce
sujet on pourrait donner un exemple de
cette nouvelle méthode pour faire voter
les réformes comment comptent-ils faire
adopter le projet de loi sur
l'immigration en écoute
nous allons réagencer les choses aussi
et découper des textes plus courts donc
il y aura bien une loi immigration il y
en aura sans doute il y aura plus sans
doute plusieurs textes immigration et
ils arriveront dans les prochaines
semaines bon vous avez largement de quoi
débattre tout simplement comme il a
conclu en fixant le cap pour la suite de
son quinquennat juste je vous prépare de
ma surprise moi je m'attendais à ce
qu'on parle santé école climat en
priorité or il y a d'autres priorités
dans ces priorités on écoute voilà le
cap
le plein emploi la réindustrialisation
l'ordre républicain est mieux vivre les
progrès avec l'école la santé et
l'écologie
c'est un peu passé vite à la fin bon
alors évidemment quand on revendique
comme priorité la croissance et leur
droit publicicain bon on a l'impression
que il est de moins en moins de gauche
le président mais là je crois qu'il y a
pas de débat sur ce sujet merci merci
pour ce tour d'horizon complet je sens
que vous avez très très envie
d'intervenir promis on va le fermer je
pense que c'est intéressant quand même
maintenant de donner la parole aux
principaux opposants des chefs de file
les principaux chefs de parties des
oppositions écoutez
ce midi nous avons entendu des propos
mécaniques et dilatoires d'un homme
apparemment de plus en plus seul qui
semble avoir perdu tous sens du réel
tout contact avec le monde extérieur y
compris peut-être avec les siens le
président de la République il y a une
fois de plus de parler pour ne rien dire
et de ce qu'on en a compris
on y retrouve que les marques
traditionnelles du mépris dont il nous a
accablé jusque là on est en fait chez
les dingue voilà on est avec un
président en fait qui est un pyromane
qui est celui qui verse chaque jour un
peu plus d'essence sur le brasier que la
lui-même allumée
à expliquer que il fustigeait des
solutions qui n'étaient pas à la hauteur
de la crise voilà donc pour la réaction
du patron de la droite parlementaire
alors chassez une school c'est lourd ok
c'est quand même ce soir aucune des
oppositions même les républicains on va
dire Macron compatible ne sont
satisfaites de cette intervention
présidentielle est-ce que vous avez pas
l'impression d'être complètement seul
écoutez je pense que dans la peur
d'actuelle on s'attendait pas à des
propos élogieux pour le président de la
République moi le chef de l'État je l'ai
trouvé courageux
il a réexpliqué l'importance de cette
réforme il parle de nécessité moi je
partage ce point de vue notamment au
regard des comparaisons européennes il a
expliqué que c'était un point obligé
pour poursuivre les grands
transformations du pays il assume la
décision qu'il a prise également de
d'utiliser le 49-3 je pense qui est
important comme chef de l'État garant
des institutions de réexpliquer ce
qu'est notre Constitution et de rappeler
de la réforme de peut-être et de
rappeler aussi un certain nombre
d'évidences que certains groupes
d'opposition extrémistes oublient c'est
que dans notre République il y a des
règles il y a une constitution qui fixe
un cadre qui a un processus législatif
qui suit son cours et que les violences
que nous voyons depuis quelques jours
sont absolument inacceptables
alors Michel Tabarro on aurait pu penser
ce soir car ici aurait été un peu plus
clément l'ordre contre le chaos quand
même à droite ça doit ça doit vous
parler non
l'impopularité qu'il prend ce risque au
nom de l'intérêt général face aux
déficit face à des générations qui
pourront supporter le poids de la dette
ça ne vous parle pas écoutez moi je
voudrais déjà rectifier un petit quelque
chose puisqu'en voyant envoyer Éric
sotti vous avez parlé d'une droite
macrocompatible ça n'est pas le cas vous
savez nous sommes dans l'opposition par
contre effectivement cette réforme des
retraits nous l'avons toujours soutenu
nous l'avons toujours appelé de nos vœux
et nous reprochons au président de la
République ne pas avoir eu le courage de
la faire lors du quinquennat précédent
c'était d'ailleurs assez amusant de
redire je pouvais pas mettre la
poussière sous le tapis j'étais obligé
de le faire non il aurait dû la faire
sur son premier quinquennat il n'a pas
eu le courage de le faire il a décidé
cette cette réforme dans un moment
particulier dans un climat social
difficile
alors qu'on a une guerre en Ukraine
alors qu'on a une inflation galopante
alors qu'on a une crise de l'énergie il
a été aussi abue assez brutal dans la
façon d'annoncer sa sa volonté de faire
cette réforme des retraites il a parlé
de 65 ans il a refusé le dialogue avec
les corps intermédiaires et vous avez
fait campagne sur les 65 ans à titre
personnel je suivais pas partie de
l'équipe de Monsieur
il n'avait rien dit depuis le 49-3 alors
il l'avait rien sur la justification sur
la manière dont il a essayé d'expliquer
aux Français le bien fondé de cette
réforme moi je peux vous n'êtes pas
convaincu alors que vous défendez je
peux lui reprocher lorsqu'il lorsqu'on
savait qu'on qu'on se rapprochait du
49-3 ou en tout cas qui avait le moment
de la CMP et les derniers jours de
discussion d'avoir refusé d'avoir
peut-être
refusé aussi à Madame borne de recevoir
les syndicats il y a une lettre vous en
souvenez qui a été adressée par les
syndicats vous savez il y a à la fois le
rôle du Parlement il est très important
et moi je suis très attaché à
représentation nationale mais d'un autre
côté aussi nous avons des corps
intermédiaires il aurait dû prendre la
peine de les écouter je sens un
durcissement chez les républicains
de sa méthode pas de pas du fond et je
suis j'aurais eu beaucoup de plaisir à
voter ce texte si nous avions pu le
voter Stéphane peut il a conseillé quand
même un regret ne pas être parvenu avec
son gouvernement à convaincre de la
nécessité de cette réforme il a expliqué
aussi qu'entre 2017 et 2022 il y avait
eu la guerre la pandémie que les caisses
étaient vides et qu'il fallait au fond
produire pour pouvoir garantir le modèle
social rien dans cette explication nous
a convaincu
non pas grand chose on savait que
Emmanuel Macron a été souvent à
l'étranger quand il y avait des
mobilisations sociales depuis deux mois
mais là ce midi on a eu l'impression
qu'il était absent du pays depuis deux
mois
moi ce qui ce qui me choque beaucoup
dans les propos du président de la
République c'est que quand vous avez 9
salariés sur 10 7 Français sur 10 qui
rejettent une réforme qu'ils ont très
bien compris parce qu'elle est injuste
parce qu'elle pénalise surtout ceux
qu'on commençait tôt et qui travaillent
dur il s'agit pas d'une foule il s'agit
d'un peuple et par ailleurs quand il en
appelle au représentants du peuple à la
alors son entourage et l'Élysée qui
s'agissait des casseurs quand ils
disaient la foule devant les
parlementaires dans Les Clos de je
précise mais depuis deux mois le pays
qui se mobilise et le pays qui rejette
ses réformes c'est l'immense majorité du
peuple et ça il n'en parle pas il ne le
prend pas en compte et quand il oppose
ce peuple mobilisait aux représentants
du peuple mais
il les a pas fait voter les
représentants du peuple il a refusé de
les faire voter les représentants du
peuple que nous sommes à l'Assemblée
nationale en utilisant le 49-3 donc si
vous voulez tout sonne faux dans dans
cette interview vous le rejet de
l'ascenseur ne vaut pas votre adhésion
c'est deux choses différentes
on a été sur la chaîne Parlement c'est
pas ici quand même sur d'autres médias
on peut peut-être le comprendre mais on
va l'aider
le vote pour une réforme tout à fait une
motion de censure qui vise à faire
chuter un gouvernement c'est quand même
deux choses de nature différente il
aurait très bien pu passer par il aurait
fallu passer par le vote de l'argent
entretenu par la première ministre sur
le sujet puisque c'est une confusion
c'est deux choses de vote qui de nature
totalement différente sur sur la
première lecture lorsque nous avions la
chance de pouvoir débattre le fait de
déposer autant d'amendements
vous avez privé les Français
malheureusement ça nous a privé d'un
débat intéressant pour les Français on
va pas refaire le match il y a une
phrase qui a fait beaucoup réagir Kevin
vaux aux yeux je vais vous demander
votre réaction globale mais je vais vous
la faire écouter c'est la comparaison
que le chef de l'État adressé entre ceux
qui cassent ceux qui bloquent avec des
factures écoutez
quand les États-Unis d'Amérique ont vécu
ce qu'ils ont vécu au Capitole quand le
Brésil a vécu ce qu'il a vécu quand vous
avez eu l'extrême violence en Allemagne
au Pays-Bas ou parfois par le passé chez
nous je vous le dit très nettement il
faut dire on respecte on écoute on
essaie d'avancer pour le pays et je vais
y revenir parce que je veux comparer le
fond de cette réforme mais on ne peut
accepter
ni les faction ni les factions
pas du tout
on combat au rassemblement national on a
été très clair on l'a toujours été
d'ailleurs on dénonce les violences on
dénonce la contestation quand elle quand
elle vire au drame entre guillemets mais
on ne va pas aller comparer des
personnes qui se battent contre une
réforme avec des manifestations qui
n'ont absolument rien à voir on n'est
pas du tout sur le même plan et la
manœuvre d'Emmanuel Macron elle est très
claire il est mal à l'aise sur la
réforme des retraites parce qu'elle est
injuste injustifiée d'ailleurs on le
voit on a juste à regarder la gestuelle
vous coupez l'image vous le regardez
avec toute sa gestuelle c'est il va
chercher le journaliste en avant il tape
avec sa main enfin il essaye de donner
une impression de de d'autorité
d'ailleurs à la fois à la nude mais
aussi au rassemblement national de ne
pas avoir de projets alternatifs ou
d'être vraiment un finançable 26
milliards pour la réforme des retraites
de Marine Le Pen ça il l'a dit
son argument son argument est totalement
à l'ouest alors premièrement il dit
qu'on nous a pas entendu effectivement
nous appelons entendu parce qu'entre les
18000 amendements de la nups qui a
monopolisé le débat et nous avec nos 200
amendements parce qu'on avait pris en
compte le fait que le gouvernement nous
avait imposé deux semaines donc on s'est
dit on s'est dit on va mettre deux on va
mettre 200 rendements pour avoir le
temps d'aller jusqu'au vote
on se retrouve finalement avec la nups
qu'en 10 000 donc effectivement en
termes de temps de parole on nous entend
moins mais il faut voir la qualité un
programme on en avait un sur les
retraites il a été convaincu combattu
entre les deux tours de l'élection
présidentielle par contre moi ce qui me
dérange dans ce qui a été dit par
Emmanuel Macron ce midi c'est que si on
regarde bien le fil rouge au final il
nous dit tout et son contraire c'est à
dire que au début il nous dit que sa
réforme des retraites elle est
essentielle importante incontournable et
qu'on ne peut pas la financer autrement
parce que les retraites ne se financent
que par le travail des actifs sur le
principe on peut être d'accord c'est ce
qui nous a été reproché d'ailleurs que
ce soit la nups au rassemblement
national quand on a proposer de taxer
les surprofis pour payer les retraites
ça nous a été reproché parce que c'est
pas comme ça qu'on finance les retraites
et puis un peu plus tard il vient nous
dire que la réforme des retraites il
était contre l'allongement de l'âge de
départ en retraite il y a 5 ans parce
que c'était pas nécessaire puis
entre-temps on a eu la crise covid on a
la guerre en Ukraine on a l'inflation il
y a de la dette donc il faut faire cette
réforme alors il faut savoir s'il faut
faire cette réforme parce qu'il y a de
la dette ça veut dire que les gens on
leur demande de travailler deux ans de
plus pour financer la dette d'Emmanuel
Macron et en réalité le problème il est
là on ne demande pas aux gens de
financer le système des retraites on
demande aux gens de financer des
recettes j'imagine en plus mais voilà
mais qui vont aller financer une dette
abyssale que le gouvernement creuse
d'année en année alors
beaucoup du système de retraite par
répartition voulu au lendemain par le
Conseil National de la Résistance
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait une
étanchéité entre le budget de la Nation
et le budget et le budget de la Sécurité
sociale et des alors après ce premier
tour de table on va parler notamment de
ce qui pourrait peut-être faire plaisir
à la gauche la taxe ou la contribution
sur les super profits peut-être la mise
sous conditions du RSA qui préfère
plaisir à la droite j'aimerais bien
votre regard Dominique Régnier est-ce
qu'il a est-ce qu'il a fait il a parlé
dans un contexte particulier avant une
très grosse manifestation attendue
demain après le rejet de justesse de la
censure il décide de parler aujourd'hui
avant tout son électorat c'est ça c'est
c'est ressouder le socle la base
l'objectif je pense pas parce que il est
pas candidat de toute façon maintenant
c'est fini donc je ne sais pas si il a
besoin de soigner son électorat il faut
qu'il fasse attention sans doute à la
stabilité du pays
parce que les choses ne partent pas dans
un sens trop mauvais rassuré et puis
mettre un peu d'ordre peut-être d'un
argumentation mais ce discours au fond
sur le courage des réformes au risque de
l'impopularité l'intérêt général contre
le peuple en tout cas la démocratie
d'opinion les sondages sont contre la
rue contre le Parlement est-ce que ça
peut passer un sujet dont je peux parler
parce que c'était pas
des réponses élaborées et qui prennent
du temps et vous allez me dire après on
n'a pas le temps donc ça marche pas ça
on peut pas faire ça il faut je vous
laisse le temps tout ce que vous avez
dit là est intéressant mais c'est à
chaque fois il faut élaborer sur
l'opinion par exemple ça argument qu'on
sert tout le temps ça ne tient pas à ça
ça ne tient pas philosophiquement ça ne
tient pas du point de vue du droit
public français ce sont deux choses
différentes l'opinion n'est pas une
contrainte de droit c'est une
information pour ceux qui veulent s'y
intéresser et les sondages qui ont été
faits sont des sondages qui sont
contestables non pas dans la qualité de
la mesure mais dans la question qui est
posée vous ne pouvez pas avoir personne
ici ne peut dire qu'il a été surpris de
voir que lorsqu'on demande aux Français
s'ils sont pour travailler dedans de
plus ils vous disent non évidemment
la question n'est pas celle-là alors la
bonne question c'est est-ce que nous
avons les moyens c'est pas moi de
répondre il y a des parlementaires ici
je peux pas sur le fond si vous voulez
c'est là que je fais
si tu es pas au parlementaire
on peut parler de politique mais quand
on est expert mais quand on est quand on
parle du fond qu'est-ce qu'il fallait
faire c'est au parlementaire de dire en
particulier ici c'est pas un expert qui
n'a pas de légitimité pour le dire s'il
y avait un débat entre expert sur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire pour les
retraites je pourrais en parler je suis
en a parlé voilà la même chose j'en
conviens
c'est en particulier dans ce lieu mais
simplement la question que doivent
trancher les parlementaires c'est de
savoir que quels sont les ressources
cette évoqué dans dans les échanges que
vous avez eu là
le scho disait le président
à travers sa formule si je pouvais
l'éviter je l'éviterais ça signifie que
200 points de vue il y a le contraste
insurmontable qui est une contrainte
budgétaire si on accorde du crédit c'est
pas le mot qu'il faut employer mais si
on accorde fois à cette à cette
justification et bien il faut en tirer
des conclusions
si on accorde pas foi il faut expliquer
pourquoi cette évaluation est fausse ou
pour être fait autrement simplifier les
choses surtout ça c'est à dire que
ni dans parmi les syndicats ni pour ce
qui est nous concerne en tout cas nous
contestons la nécessité d'une réforme
des retraites mais il y a plusieurs
façons de réformer les retraites
d'ailleurs les organisations syndicales
et avaient beaucoup de propositions un
peu différentes d'un syndic à l'autre
mais ils ont mis sur la table des
propositions qui n'ont pas été prise en
compte en fait il y a la question et pas
de savoir s'il faut réformer ou pas s'il
y a pas voilà il y a d'autres solutions
je vous juste en donner une comme ça
parce que ça ça fait écho à ce que
disait le président de la République
avec la changement de fiscalité sur les
dividendes il y a beaucoup plus de
rémunération par dividendes depuis
maintenant quelques années depuis 2018
date de la réforme sur la flat tac le
fait par exemple de soumettre les
dividendes que la rémunération du
capital au même niveau de cotisation en
retraite que la rémunération du travail
que sont les salaires le même pas plus
moi c'est 20 milliards de plus dans
lesquels c'est une autre façon de de
financer la réforme des retraites et
moins injuste pour ceux qui travaillent
dur et qui font les métiers pénis
c'est pas forcément un fléchage fiscal
des dividendes vers les retraites mais
c'est une contribution qu'il a qualifié
d'exceptionnel sur les super profits il
a même parlé vous l'avez entendu tout à
l'heure de cynisme de certaines
entreprises ça devrait faire plaisir à
la gauche et pourtant manuel Bompard
pour les insoumis estime que c'est trop
tard
aujourd'hui il fait mine de vouloir
avancer en disant que peut-être qu'il
mettrait en place une contribution pour
les entreprises qui s'engageraient dans
des rachats d'actions on parle pas du
tout de la même chose ça concerne une
toute petite partie une toute petite
minorité des entreprises qui ont fait
des profits extraordinaires ces derniers
mois et ces dernières années c'est de la
poudre de perlimpinpin pour faire croire
du sucré comme vous dites mais il y a
pas d'amour avec des preuves d'amour et
le président est un spécialiste de la
déclaration amoureuse pipotée alors
Charles César pourquoi au fond cet axe
ou cette contribution qui n'était pas
possible trop compliquée à mettre en
oeuvre est possible aujourd'hui en fait
on l'a déjà fait en partie il l'a
rappelé d'ailleurs le chef de l'État
puisque les surprofis sur qui concerne
les entreprises de l'énergie en réalité
sont déjà taxés et c'est sur profit sont
récupérés notamment avec ça qu'on a
financé les mesures derniers mois
pour aider les Français dans cette
période d'inflation
plus loin sur la taxe on a un débat qui
monte sur la question des rachats
rachats d'actions et moi je trouve ça
plutôt plutôt encourageant que le
gouvernement s'y attelle voilà bonne
nouvelle c'est jamais trop tard pour les
Français Stéphane peut
le problème c'est la crédibilité de la
mesure quand le président de la
République parle de la pénibilité alors
que la loi qui a été adoptée par 49-3 à
retirer un amendement du Sénat sur
l'exposition aux produits chimiques
c'est-à-dire à affaibli les critères de
pénibilité qui eux-mêmes avaient déjà
été affaibli dans une loi précédente par
la même majorité comment voulez-vous
donner crédit au président de la
République quand il parle après le 49-3
des critères de pénibilité que lui-même
a enlevé c'est comme quand il parle des
comme sur la possibilité
nous on a fait une proposition
d'amendement
celle que je vous ai décrite tout à
l'heure sur une contribution équivalente
des revenus capital et des revenus du
travail
si vous voulez ce que je veux vous
expliquer c'est que là où les Français
mais c'est pas seulement moi comme
parlementaire d'opposition à la limite
ce serait pas très important mais là où
les Français ne croient plus le
président de la République quand il
s'étonne par exemple qu'il y a des
accords de branche où il y a des
salaires en dessous du SMIC mais cet été
il y a une loi sur le pouvoir d'achat on
a déposé une multitude d'amendements
pour surseoir à cette anomalie qui fait
que vous avez un SMIC et que vous avez
des accords de branche où il y a des
rémunérations en dessous du SMIC
les syndicats de l'ont proposé on leur a
refusé donc si vous voulez le président
de la République n'est pas crédible
quand il revient sur des choses qu'ils
ont sur lesquels ils ont combattu pas
plus tard que la semaine dernière moi je
veux répondre rapidement quand même que
on l'oublie beaucoup la France est quand
même le pays d'Europe ou l'inflation a
été le plus jugulé et ça c'est l'action
du Président de la République et
organise des finances fin du quinquennat
précédent et début du quinquennat actuel
la loi qui a été votée cet été vous le
savez et ça a été une loi d'urgence qui
a été préparée rapidement c'était le
premier grand texte de la législature le
sujet qui évoque Stéphane peut moi je
pense que ça mériterait qu'on en reparle
dans un texte dont je comprends que le
président voudrait qu'on discute autour
du travail du travail et de l'emploi
mais alors justement loi travail on
entend parler d'usure professionnelle de
critères de pénibilité pourquoi pas même
de semaines des quatre jours il veut
renouer le dialogue compliqué quand même
regarder la réaction ce soir de Laurent
Berger de la CFDT
déni et mensonges Macron 2023 refait
l'histoire et ment pour masquer son
incapacité à trouver une majorité pour
voter sa réforme injuste il fallait dire
que Emmanuel Macron l'accusait de ne pas
avoir de contre-projet sur sur les
retraites Kevin ma vieux vous pensez
qu'il est possible encore de remettre
autour de la même table un la CGT pour
parler travaille je pense que là
Emmanuel Macron va pouvoir sortir les
rames et va avoir beaucoup de mal dans
le contexte actuel à faire revenir les
représentants syndicaux autour de la
table sur une loi concernant la retraite
ou le travail mais en tant que de la
nation est-ce que vous le souhaitez au
rassemblement national est-ce que la
responsabilité n'est pas de dire essayer
de vous reparler pour l'intérêt des
Français sur des textes qui sont quand
même beaucoup plus on va dire positifs
après l'effort le réconfort avec ce loi
travail normalement sur le principe il
faut se parler on est dans une
république une démocratie maintenant on
a un président de la République qui
depuis des années laisse parler mais
n'écoute pas n'entend pas il sait il
décide il tronche tout seul et
d'ailleurs dans l'allocution de ce midi
parce que pour l'instant on parle
beaucoup retraite et c'est important
mais il y a quelque chose de grave qui a
été annoncé dans la locution de ce midi
et qui ne ressort pas tant que ça dans
les dans les médias il a quand même
annoncé
une stratégie du saucissonnage entre
guillemets pour les futurs réformes
c'est à dire que Emmanuel Macron nous a
appris qu'à partir de maintenant il va
gouverner avec des majorités de
circonstances mais ne laissera pas au
parlementaire la possibilité de donner
leur avis sur la philosophie d'un texte
je m'explique je prends un exemple tout
bête la réforme immigration qui devait
arriver on sait pas quand elle arrivera
du coup mais la réforme immigration ça
veut dire que vous avez un texte avec
une philosophie globale le parlementaire
doit voter article par article avec les
amendements mais il y a aussi la
philosophie qui est votée derrière et ça
veut dire que là il va faire quoi il va
nous faire une petite réformète où il va
vouloir donner leur papier à toutes les
personnes qui travaillent comme ça ça
plaira à la gauche la gauche votre avec
lui majorité de circonstances puis deux
mois après il va nous ramener un texte
en disant et puis les étrangers on va
les délinquants par exemple on va les
renvoyer dans leur pays et puis comme ça
on aura une majorité avec le et on va
faire ça pendant quatre ans elle est où
la démocratie quand on ne laisse pas au
parlementaire la possibilité de voter
sur la philosophie d'un texte parce que
il y a une philosophie derrière on peut
être d'accord avec une première partie
pas avec l'autre mais il y a une
philosophie à laquelle les
parlementaires doivent adhérer et là le
gouvernement est Emmanuel Macron est en
train de faire de l'anti parlementarisme
il l'a commencé avec ses 49-3 mais bien
sûr que si ça mais bien sûr que si vous
allez répondre parce que elle est lourde
un dialogue avec personne le
saucissonage
des textes on va aller chercher des
majorités à droite à gauche il a remis
en cause le rôle du Parlement la
procédure législative que le
gouvernement qui est quand même issu de
la majorité certes relative et majorité
quand même à l'Assemblée à l'Assemblée
nationale
décide des projets de loi qui vont au
Parlement c'est le droit que lui confère
la Constitution donc moi je veux bien
que depuis quelques jours il y a un
espèce de grande importance quoi général
sur le texte constitutionnel mais
faisons très attention chers collègues
parce que au rythme on va et avec des
des propos tels que vous les tenez
on va faire voler en éclat notre
Constitution mais pas du tout la
Constitution prévoit que la gouvernement
dépose des projets de loi et bien sûr
mais ça je les parlementaires ont par
ailleurs la faculté de déposer des
propositions de loi et les projets de
loi sont préparés et écrits par le
gouvernement et ensuite ils sont
discutés et amendés par le Parlement et
le gouvernement a le droit de définir le
contenu des textes et puis des textes un
peu plus resserrés un peu plus ramassés
je crois que c'est quand même la une
attente collective assez transpartie
pour essayer de trouver des majorités
je pense par exemple à la loi e NR qu'on
a énergie renouvelable qu'on a examiné
il y a quelques semaines c'était un
texte très long très compliqué et on a
été plusieurs à se dire franchement
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas pu faire plus
ramasser plus simple Michel tabaron
réformé sans passer nécessairement par
la loi parce qu'il a aussi par les le
président qui n'assume pas aujourd'hui
le texte qui a été présenté et adopté
avec le 49-3 il n'a pas valorisé les
éléments de sa de sa retraite on a le
sentiment qui a il est très mal à l'aise
vis-à-vis de ce texte cette réforme des
retraites elle était nécessaire il a
montré avec son graphique qui est un
petit peu grotesque aujourd'hui parce
qu'il nous fait sur toutes les émissions
mais la nécessité alors que dans les
autres pays européens nous nous
retrouvons avec des départs à la
retraite très très tardifs on voit bien
qu'il n'a pas assumé alors qu'en réalité
cette réforme des retraites était
nécessaire la méthode
erreur il aurait dû il aurait dû venir
même mais avant même de commencer ce
texte se rendre compte que si les
personnes sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
c'est parce que les salaires sont
faibles c'est parce que malheureusement
les gens n'arrivent pas les Français
n'arrivent pas à faire leurs courses
correctement c'est parce qu'il y a une
crise de l'énergie qui qui coûte très
cher et c'est ce contexte là qui fait
que les personnes sont dans la rue
à la droite aussi
des textes avec des des tronçons moi je
pense que c'est une grosse erreur c'est
à dire c'est le constat finalement de ce
en même temps avec lui on peut pas aller
chercher de temps en temps une majorité
d'un côté une majorité d'un autre il a
essayé de le faire il a slalomer il a
réussi à tenir quelques mois mais en
réalité il a besoin un engagement fort
vis-à-vis des Français et avoir du
courage politique c'est-à-dire une
solution remaniement écoutez ça c'est
son problème savoir s'il doit garder la
dame borne pas s'il doit aussi parler et
je voudrais terminer pour régler le
problème des Français
je voudrais vous entendre quand même sur
sur cette main tendue lorsqu'il s'agit
d'élargir la majorité il l'a très
clairement dit avec la droite il a même
parlé pourquoi pas avec la gauche
j'imagine hors nup vous êtes prêtes à
l'accepter cette main tendue
un gouvernement d'union
nationale non voilà c'est aujourd'hui il
a il a besoin de nous réunir sur quelque
chose qui qui ressemble à nos
engagements politiques on a une famille
politique qui a défini un certain nombre
de valeurs et de règles on va pas se
retrouver dans un échéance qui est très
très large et là ce serait une coalition
pas de coalition avec les LR qui n'ont
absolument
il a dit une chose aussi qui doit tous
nous interpeller
je le cite on passe trop par la loi
j'ai une majorité c'est inquiétant dans
une démocratie qu'on faisait un
président de la République qui dit tout
ne se fait pas par la loi on passe trop
par la loi donc du coup j'ai une
majoritaire relative à l'Assemblée
nationale et donc je vais essayer de
réformer le pays en évitant de passer
par la loi mais dans une démocratie la
loi reste quand même la loi commune
celle qui est élaborée par les
représentants du peuple et il y a quand
même la meilleure véhicule pour faire
fonctionner une démocratie que la loi
votée et discutée par les représentants
du peuple c'est dit et ce sera le mot de
la fin merci beaucoup je trouve que ce
débat a bien permis de prendre la
température des des blocs politiques ici
à l'Assemblée ou il n'y a plus de
majorité absolue merci à vous d'avoir
participé à ce débat en direct vous
restez avec moi Dominique Régnier dans
une dizaine de minutes vous les voyez
nous affranchis pour leur parti pris
Thomas l'estavel ce soir va nous alerter
sur ces images produites par les robots
d'intelligence artificielle la porte
ouverte à toutes les manipulations au
centre c'est Richard Werly tout sourire
qui doute des JO de Paris 2024 face au
chaos des des retraites et puis
thibaulténock va revenir sur une
audition importante celle du journaliste
Rachid m Barki ex BFM TV dans le cadre
de la commission d'enquête sur les
soupçons d'ingérence étrangères ce sera
Bourbon express à tout à l'heure les
amis mais d'abord Dominique Régnier gros
plan sur votre enquête la Fonda Paul
sort ce week-end dans le cadre de la
Journée du Livre politique une étude
très fouillée sur les liens entre médias
réseaux sociaux et élections c'est
passionnant regardez quelques éléments
qui nous est résumé par l'invitation de
Maïté Frémont
si on vous invite Dominique Régnier
c'est pour nous expliquer comment la
méfiance envers les médias et la crise
politique sont liées et comment les
réseaux sociaux impactent l'opinion des
électeurs
Dominique Régnier vous êtes politologue
professeur des universités à Sciences Po
directeur de la Fondation pour
l'innovation politique et vous publiez
une enquête de référence sur les sources
d'information utilisées par les
électeurs pour suivre les dernières
présidentielles et législatives premier
constat les médias traditionnels télé
presse écrite et radio garde leur
leadership même si seulement quatre
Français sur dix disent avoir confiance
en l'information délivrée un rejet des
format classique au profit des réseaux
sociaux qui bouleverse notre rapport à
l'information et à la politique selon
votre étude 92% des électeurs utilisent
au moins un réseau social comme Facebook
TikTok Instagram ou encore YouTube les
réseaux sociaux moteurs de la
contestation c'est là que le mouvement
des gilets jaunes a débuté puis
prospérer
idem pour les anti-vaccins qui ont pu
virer leur théorie
nouvel espace public cela n'a pas
échappé aux élus qui sont en partent
également d'un bout à l'autre de
l'échiquier politique
ne veut pas régler vos projets vos
problèmes de pouvoir d'achat
je passe juste vite fait vous dire salut
et vous dire que c'est quand même assez
incroyable d'être dans une salle ah oui
à huis clos avec des parlementaires qui
sont en apesanteur social aussi forte
vous êtes une bande de tiktokers qui
cherche le buzz je crois que jamais dans
l'histoire la jeunesse n'a été aussi
politisée parce qu'elle n'a jamais été
aussi informée avec les réseaux sociaux
elle reçoit des notifications sur toutes
les actualités et en plus elle est
intéressée à la politique mais c'est
plus une défiance vis-à-vis des
institutions recours à ce type de
communication et nature à rendre les
élus plus plus proche des Français je
n'en sais rien alors plusieurs questions
ce soir Dominique Régnier les réseaux
sociaux sont-ils un purificateur de
radicalité sont-ils des alliés ou des
ennemis pour retrouver la confiance des
Français dans leurs élus et dans les
médias faut-il interdire l'accès des
élus aux réseaux sociaux réponse premier
le problème que nous avons aujourd'hui
c'est que il faut rester fidèle à nos
principes notamment la liberté de
communiquer de discuter enfin ce qu'ils
font de notre système politique mais
avec une configuration une architecture
qui a bouleversé tout cela les réseaux
sociaux en sont un exemple remarquable
et redoutable moi je voudrais quand même
rappeler que en un mot mais la
démocratie à laquelle nous tenons
beaucoup la démocratie pluraliste avec
des élections un parlement etc en gros
ça ça date de la fin de 19e siècle c'est
ce moment-là au même moment qui est
apparu la presse
et les deux ont vraiment fait chemin
route commune
jusque je dirais au début des années 90
toutes s'est passée merveilleusement
bien ça veut pas dire que les relations
étaient nécessairesment bonnes mais là
et des l'autre a existé à faire campagne
a expliqué à interroger interpellé etc
c'est le cas aujourd'hui c'est plus le
cas aujourd'hui la numérisation nous
enlève la maîtrise de l'espace public on
le sait ce sont des plateformes
transnationales elles ne sont pas
françaises américaines chinoises aussi
maintenant sur lesquels nous n'avons
absolument pas de pouvoir en réalité
nous sommes soumis dans notre espace
public c'est tout à fait dramatique d'un
point de vue historiquement je ne sais
même pas si c'est tenable la démocratie
en se régime là nous avons un espace
public dans l'opinion
communication échange campagne etc qui
appartient à un ordre dans le maîtrisons
absolument pas les composantes et même
les libertés sont pas les mêmes le
régime des libertés n'est pas le même
sur les réseaux sociaux il sera plutôt
là-dessus par exemple sur certains
appels à la haine et plus intolérant sur
autre chose alors je voudrais qu'on
revienne à votre étude dans l'ordre en
parlant d'abord des médias puis ensuite
du lien avec la question de la crise
démocratique et la question électorale
vous dites la crise des médias
traditionnels à plusieurs dimensions
c'est d'abord une crise de confiance si
Français sur 10 non plus confiance dans
les informations délivrées comment
l'expliquer c'est un aspect vous avez
raison d'un système là-dessus parce que
c'est l'autre aspect diplôme on parle
souvent de la crise de la représentation
politique mais pas assez de la crise de
représentation médiatique là vous vous
souvenez juste titre cet aspect là je
pense qu'il y a une part de conséquences
de ce système numérique sur lequel nous
avons tous désormais moi j'appelle ça
dans mes travaux l'individu média nous
avons tous désormais avec nos outils les
smartphones la capacité à faire vraiment
de l'image du son de la photo de montage
tout ce que l'on veut quasiment avec une
très bonne qualité Haute Définition etc
nous sommes tous des médias on n'avait
jamais pensé évidemment depuis Gutenberg
on avait jamais pensé qu'un jour
l'auditoire serait composée de médias
c'est un espèce de retournement bizarre
c'est un cas limite et donc c'est ces
individus médias évidemment comme
l'humanité ils sont divers mais il y a
une place énorme pour la contestation
des faits rapportés par les
professionnels que sont les journalistes
ce dont nous avons un grand besoin
aujourd'hui c'est pas suffisamment dit
ce sont des professionnels de
l'information capables de labelliser ce
qui est juste ce qui ne l'est pas ce qui
est peut-être juste ce qui est à
vérifier mais dans cette configuration
là qui d'ailleurs en fait en fait la
promotion philosophique l'idée que nous
sommes tous des journalistes tous
capables de dire quelle est la réalité
etc ce qui n'est pas vrai il y a une
méthode il y a une formation etc
déontologie voilà donc c'est c'est une
façon de niveler la production
d'information qui est mécanique aussi
parce que chacun peut un effet injecter
du contenu alors on a parlé de la crise
de confiance il y a une deuxième
dimension dans la crise
des médias traditionnels c'est ce que
vous appelez la crise de la
représentation médiatique est-ce que
vous parlez au fond je ne me reconnais
pas dans les informations parce qu'elles
ne me concerne pas c'est très frappant
et c'est très constant on a fait
plusieurs études à ce sujet
56% des Français ont l'impression que
les sujets traités ne les consonnent
les médias qu'ils regardent les grands
médias classiques ne les concernent pas
ne parle pas de leur vie et qu'il n'y
reconnaissent pas leur existence et je
pense que là c'est intéressant parce que
c'est une alerte aussi à mon avis il y a
un élément qu'il faut retenir et qui que
je trouve fondé dans l'analyse que font
les les spectateurs les auditeurs qui
tient au fait français que la production
médiatique en France elle est
sociologiquement à mon avis trop
homogène trop métropolitaine et trop
parisienne et donc tout ça c'est des
filtres des biais naturels c'est comme
ça qui font que les métiers de la
télévision le métier de la radio et du
journaliste sont excessivement je dirais
adapter à un schéma culturel un schéma
sociologiquement sont trop à gauche
alors il y a une orientation à gauche
qui est très nette dans le monde
médiatique c'est certain on l'a on l'a
c'est plus trop vrai ça aujourd'hui
encore aujourd'hui
vous parlez d'une presse par prenons la
prenons la presse prenons la radio à la
télévision publique c'est très net et
donc je pense que là c'est quelque chose
de très visible et et et après tous ces
news personne ne paye pour cnews donc
cette représentation là manque mais
c'est pas ça c'est pas une affaire de
c'est pas qu'une question d'opinion
par exemple moi je vous donne un exemple
on parle presque jamais ou très peu des
entrepreneurs qui sont souvent des
personnes confrontées à de grandes
difficultés souvent dans une vie très
modeste l'entrepreneur il est
nécessairement spéculateur puissant
grand etc non c'est pas ça la vérité en
France de l'entreprise mais l'entreprise
n'est pas représentée dans sa réalité
cet exemple on en trouverait dans les
grands médias traditionnels audiovisuel
dernière dimension de la crise des
médias c'est la lassitude la fatigue
informationnelle face à un monde qui
angoisse un monde chaotique c'est les
chiffres sont impressionnants Français
sur quatre rejettent tout simplement
l'actualité oui ça évitement de
l'actualité
et quand on demande mais pourquoi la
réponse qui vient en numéro 1 c'est ça
me déprime et ou alors de deuxième
élément de réponse parce que c'est c'est
il y avait plusieurs responsables je ne
peux pas agir et donc je préfère ne pas
savoir c'est d'ailleurs très proche de
la notion de déprime je ne peux pas agir
et donc ça me ça me perturbe
profondément il y a un effet des médias
nouveaux alors d'abord les chaînes
d'information continue ensuite les
réseaux sociaux parce que c'est 24
heures sur 24 aussi mais je crois qu'il
y a aussi dans ce temps tout cela un
effet de l'époque une charge
événementielle considérable qui est
souvent malheureusement dramatique et il
est certain on le sait par la
psychologie que nous tous nous avons
chaos du monde plus que le traitement de
ce chaos il est là devant nous qui est
limité on ne peut pas consacrer trop de
temps à tout cela alors cette crise dont
on a vu les différentes dimensions de de
la représentation médiatique
s'accompagne d'une crise de la
représentation politique est-ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer ce lien là est-ce
que ceux qui qui doutent des médias
traditionnels s'abstiennent plus se
réfugie dans des réseaux sociaux dans la
protestation quelles sont ses liens oui
alors il y a il y a un lien entre
l'abstention et cette perception d'un
monde qui ne me représente pas ni
médiatiquement ni politiquement il y a
aussi un lien mais il faudrait rentrer
dans le détail de l'étude mais il y a
aussi un lien entre certains
usages des réseaux sociaux et un
comportement un vote prestataires mais à
condition de ne pas simplifier cela
parce qu'il y a quelque chose comme une
espèce d'homologie de ressemblance entre
la remise en cause des parties de
gouvernement par des partis populistes
d'un côté et de l'autre la remise en
cause des médias classiques
professionnels par des médias sociaux
d'amateurs il y a vraiment un lien et on
l'a vu beaucoup pendant la crise des
gilets jaunes on le voit à nouveau
pendant la crise de la réforme de la
retraite mais cependant il ne faut pas
simplifier et caricaturer ni les réseaux
sociaux ni les chaînes d'information
continue ne relèvent d'un monde
absolument homogène par exemple les
macronistes sont très représentés sur
cnews ou on trouve également beaucoup de
d'amis d'Éric Zemmour mais c'est pas un
peu plus complexe que je dirais les
préjugés pourraient le donner à penser
il y a aussi des éléments très
intéressants on en parlera tout ailleurs
tout à l'heure d'ailleurs sur la
question de l'ingérence par les
puissances étrangères dans dans les
campagnes électorales via les réseaux
sociaux via les usinatrols notamment
venus de Russie optimaux sur ce débat
sur TikTok vous avez vu que il va être
interdit totalement ce réseau social ce
réseau chinois aux États-Unis est-ce que
vous pensez qu'il faut en venir à ce
genre d'interdirections
parce que comme chacun le sait nous ne
pouvons pas faire la même chose en Chine
cet asymétrie est en soi un problème il
y a 26 millions de Français sur Tik Tok
une majorité de jeunes moins de 24 ans
même ça commence à 11 ans l'influence
est très forte les informations
inspirées sont considérables il y a un
vrai problème d'ordre public de sécurité
publique même il me paraît tant de poser
la question de ce type de réseaux
sociaux merci beaucoup Dominique Régnier
je renvoie donc à cette étude que vous
nous avez révélé et bien en premier qui
parait ce week-end dans le cadre de la
Journée du Livre politique dont vous le
savez LCP est partenaire vous restez
avec moi il vous faire réagir les
affranchis pour leur parti pris on les
accueille tout de suite
bonsoir à vous les affranchis Richard
Werly du quotidien suisse Blick Thomas
l'estavel de pour l'économie qui
collabora L'Express notamment et puis
Bourbon Express bien sûr l'histoire du
jour à l'Assemblée nous est racontée ce
soir partie beau et noces bonsoir
Thibault bonsoir je le disais l'ex
journaliste de BFM TV Rachid Mbarki a
été auditionné dans le cadre de la
commission d'enquête sur les ingérons
étrangères vous l'avez suivi pour nous
oui l'affaire mbarquer à faire dont vous
avez sans doute entendu parler mais que
je vais néanmoins vous résumer le 2
février dernier le média politique au
révèle que le présentateur du journal de
la nuit sur BFM a été suspendu par la
direction pour soupçon de manipulation
d'informations des soupçons découverts
comment et bien par une enquête une
vaste enquête internationale sur des
réseaux secrets de fake news une enquête
dans laquelle apparaît donc le nom de
Rachid embarki cité par un agent d'une
officine israélienne une officine
spécialisée dans la la manipulation
d'informations qui vendraient ces
services dans le monde entier et qui
déclare avoir fait des passer des
informations sur BFM TV vidéo à l'appui
la piste remonte jusqu'à Rachid embarki
le journaliste est alors soupçonné
d'avoir diffusé une dizaine de séquences
d'un intérêt disons douteux au cours des
24 derniers mois par exemple en faveur
du Maroc ou d'un général soudanais des
informations non validées par sa
hiérarchie qui lui reproche justement et
bien d'avoir cours circuité des circuits
habituels et qui le licencie fin février
est porte plainte pour corruption
passive et abus de confiance alors on a
les idées bien en place maintenant
qu'a-t-il dit racheter des Marquis pour
se défendre et bien pendant près de
trois heures devant les comités de
députés de la commission d'enquête le
journaliste a nié toute malhonnêteté il
estime être victime d'un amalgame je le
cite de calomnie même tout ce que l'on
me reproche est faux a-t-il résumé
aujourd'hui je dis que non vous n'avez
pas été manipulé non parce que chacune
des informations que j'ai données
étaient vrais vérifiable et vérifié je
n'ai rien fait dans le dos de personnes
tout ce que j'ai fait était visible de
tout le monde
alors sur le fait que des informations
étaient passées à l'antenne sans
validation qu'a-t-il répondu
au passage il a mouillé son employeur
son ex employeur mes textes étaient
écrits à l'avance a-t-il dit ils étaient
visibles par tous comme les images s'il
y a des choses qui n'ont pas été
validées c'est qu'il n'y avait pas de
process de validation a-t-il avancé
sincèrement
ce process n'existait pas
il y a pas de processus
il y avait des discussions avec ma
hiérarchie la rédacteur la rédactrice en
chef en l'occurrence
sur les sujets qui étaient les plus
importants du journal non il n'y avait
pas de validation de toutes les
séquences il y avait des validation de
certaines séquences mais pas toutes
bien et sur la nature de ces
informations et surtout leurs sources
d'embarqua a reconnu être en contact
avec un homme Jean-Pierre Duthion un
lobbyiste qui lui a fourni des
informations et des images notamment sur
le Maroc mais il dit ne jamais avoir
soupçonné qu'il pouvait s'agir d'un
agent d'influence quelqu'un que j'ai
rencontré il y a quelques années
qui était une de mes sources parmi
d'autres cette personne me donnait de
relativement régulièrement des
informations je ne savais pas
pour qui travailler précisément monsieur
Duthion alors le problème c'est que
Jean-Pierre Duthion est un lobby c'est
un peu vantard qui se félicite en privé
de rémunérer des journalistes pour faire
passer des informations et des sujets
notamment pour des puissances étrangères
alors est-ce qu'il y a eu rémunération
alors Rachida a répondu par la négative
la seule personne qui me payait c'était
mon employeur je n'ai jamais accepté
quoi que ce soit de quelqu'un qui me
donnait des informations rappelons qu'il
s'exprimait devant une commission
d'enquête donc sous serment pour finir
il a conclu l'audition en larmes disant
ça réputation et sa carrière détruite on
ressort de cette audition très
circonspect naïveté ou culpabilité ce
n'était pas au député dans décidé ce
sera le travail de la justice merci
beaucoup c'est très clair qu'est-ce
qu'elle vous inspire c'est incroyable à
faire bien sûr je veux pas rentrer
évidemment sur les frais
il faut le laisser se défendre mais ce
qui me frappe c'est d'une part le fait
que on le disait tout à l'heure on a
vraiment besoin de défendre la
profession des journalistes de la
formation la déontologie la rigueur
l'encadrement il faut être faut aider
les journalistes faut pas qu'il soit
tout seul faut pas qu'il se trouve en
état de faiblesse etc et puis
deuxièmement cette
caractère très pénétrable de nos
sociétés par la numérisation qui
fragilisent dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
c'est injuste et c'est une réalité
davantage des systèmes ouverts
démocratique que les systèmes fermés
autoritaires donc nous sommes là dans
une architecture qui nous est
défavorable nous en étions réjouis je
crois que c'est encore très positif mais
il faut vraiment qu'on ait à l'esprit
que des états hostiles je ne parle pas
ici de ce qui a été évoqué mais on le
sait pour la Chine on le sait pour la
Russie on le sait pour l'Iran ou la
Turquie par exemple et d'autres encore
vont utiliser le numérique notre
ouverture notre amour de la liberté pour
s'immiscer parasiter les campagnes
électorales on l'a vu pour le brexit
dans les États-Unis donc c'est un c'est
quand même un sujet sur lequel on doit
se mobiliser
avec vous Richard les JO quelle fierté
Paris 2024 c'est dans c'est dans un an
tout pile et d'ailleurs les bénévoles
l'appel au bénévoles a été lancé
aujourd'hui vous posez la question qui
fâche on sera pas prêt vous n'y croyez
pas écoutez Myriam alors le slogan c'est
vivez l'expérience d'une vie c'est le
slogan de cette campagne de recrutement
de volontaire donc candidaté et vous
serez peut-être parmi les milliers
d'autres jeunes qui seront soit présents
au village des athlètes donc de
saint-denis-playel ou bien si vous êtes
encore plus chanceux et bien vous serez
peut-être là le jour du 26 juillet 2024
avec cette parade sur la scène pour la
cérémonie d'ouverture
d'austerlitza trocadéroz vous imaginez
le défilé les quais Notre-Dame restaurer
le Louvre bref Paris au centre du monde
sauf que voilà on connaît tous ceux qui
se passe en ce moment dans les rues de
Paris alors Myriam pardon au
téléspectateurs mais moi je n'arrive pas
tellement à y croire ces jours-ci parce
que cette parade mondialisée ce grand
spectacle cette compétition suivie dans
le monde entier dont on parlise aussi à
l'Assemblée nationale puisqu'on débat en
ce moment de la loi sur les jeux
olympiques comment la conjuguer avec les
ordures qui mon scène les barricades les
brasiers j'ai même décroché mon
téléphone j'ai appelé à Lausanne au
siège du Comité international olympique
j'ai quelques copains et bien
figurez-vous que quand on leur pose la
question ils ont un peu de la peine à
répondre que oui ça se passera bien bref
tout le monde est inquiet c'est dans un
an quand même hein c'est dans longtemps
la France elle les a voulu ces jeunes
non ça on est bien d'accord
2024 rappelons-le quand même c'est pour
marquer le Center des JO de 1924 c'est
le symbole c'est le cadre c'était le
baron Pierre de Coubertin mais ce qu'on
oublie un peu c'est qu'avant les JO de
1924 il y avait eu ce de 1900 au moment
de l'exposition universelle et il ne
s'était pas bien passé du tout c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que couverta en avait
demandé un peu plus tard parce qu'à
l'époque il y avait une concurrence
effrénée entre d'un côté les concours
sportifs de l'Exposition universelle et
de l'autre ces deuxièmes Olympiades des
temps modernes alors oui je m'interroge
juste pour un petit rappel en 1924 au
stade olympique de Colombes la France
avait accueilli 4 pas de délégation de
payant compétition elles seront près de
200 ces délégations dans un an alors un
petit test allez ici pour finir sur ce
plateau Dominique Régnier je voudrais
bien savoir si je suis le seul
pessimiste les JO de l'été de 2024 dans
Paris est-ce que vous y croyez moi je
partage votre inquiétude
j'espère que ça se déroulera bien
on a un peu de temps encore pour pour
être sécurité
vous allez nous montrer ce soir Thomas
estavay pour terminer des images
saisissantes alors en effet Myriam on a
des photos de Donald Trump arrêté par la
police qui ont fait le buzz ces derniers
jours sur les réseaux sociaux vous les
voyez ici à l'image alors sachez
qu'elles sont fausses tout comme ces
photos bucoliques de Barack Obama et
d'Angela Merkel qu'on voit défiler à
l'écran alors ils sont en train de
couler des jours heureux à la plage et
puis une petite dernière avec des
clichés d'Emmanuel Macron qui joue avec
le feu et il ne faut voir aucun rapport
avec le 49-3 évidemment bien vous aussi
alors ces bluffant parfaite contrefaçon
elles viennent d'où ces images alors ces
images donc vous l'aurez compris c'est
des œuvres Numériques elles ont été
créées par des algorithmes
d'intelligence artificielle alors ces
derniers temps ici aux affranchis on
vous a beaucoup parlé de tchat GPT donc
ce fameux robot conversationnel à qui
faire dire à peu près tout et n'importe
quoi la startup californienne open hey
high qui a développé carte GPT a créé un
équivalent sous forme pour les images
qui s'appelle Dali alors Dali qui
s'écrit da2l tiret e c'est gratuit donc
vous pouvez l'essayer Myriam et vous
serez bluffé l'intelligence a fait
artificielle elle peut faire des photos
de n'importe qui et de n'importe quoi
alors le principe c'est toujours le même
et c'est le même que pour chat GPT en
fait un algorithme est entraîné à
analyser des milliers et des milliers
d'images qui sont accompagnés d'une
description écrite et ensuite le
programme est capable de restituer et de
combiner ces images à la demande et de
façon de plus en plus pertinente de
surdalis vous pouvez vraiment laisser
aller votre créativité vous pouvez
demander une photo de une photo de
pangolin au volant d'une Formule 1 ou
encore de Vladimir Poutine qui va danser
la valse avec Chichin ping sur Saturne
mais alors la star du moment c'est la
société midjornay c'est la fameuse
startup qui a généré les images qu'on
voyait tout à l'heure d'Obama et de
Trump il faut imaginer que c'est un
laboratoire de 11 personnes seulement
qui a conçu cet algorithme qui a été
créé l'an dernier et qui veut déjà
plusieurs milliards d'euros c'est quand
même très très inquiétant les
manipulations est-ce qu'on va avoir de
grands peintres à l'avenir si
l'intelligence artificielle fabrique des
tableaux de maître effectivement alors
donc tous ces SCI est très amusant en
première abord et les réseaux sociaux
sont deslectes mais c'est vrai que quand
on se projette dans l'avenir c'est un
peu flippant midjorn donne des sueurs
froides pour ainsi dire au graphiste ou
au photographe d'abord parce que les
droits d'auteurs ne sont pas respectés
donc en fait l'algorithme vient piocher
sans distinction des photos disponibles
sur Internet et sans aucun respect des
droits d'auteur et encore pire il
commence déjà à concurrencer des humains
donc on a une agence de communication au
guilvy qui a récemment utilisé Dali le
fameux algorithme pour créer une
publicité Nestlé incroyable donc c'est
la laitière de Vermeer qu'ils ont
programmé en version étendue donc avec
le reste de la de l'image qu'on pouvait
imaginer à l'époque et autre exemple
d'ores et déjà des restaurateurs n'ont
plus besoin de photographes pour
illustrer leur menu voyez ce que on a
plusieurs versions de la semaine à la V5
c'est la plus récente on voit à quel
point maintenant on peut totalement se
passer de photographes puisque le menu
il est déjà sur demande sans compter que
il y a toute une série d'emplois
détruits à la clé donc des emplois
effectivement de photographes et puis il
y a aussi une dimension qui est
dangereuse et inquiétante et qui rejoint
ce que vous disiez Dominique renier
c'est que ces intelligences
artificielles peuvent mettre en péril
nos démocratie nos systèmes ouverts
alors le complotisme c'est jamais aussi
bien porté on sait que les photos
qu'elles soient vrai ou fausse sont
reprises à un rythme incroyable sur les
réseaux sociaux au prix d'un public qui
peut être très crédule et on pourrait
tout à fait imaginer que demain des
hackers diffusent dans des médias russes
de fausses images d'une victoire
militaire en Ukraine pour galvaniser la
population donc la désinformation a
malheureusement de beaux jours devant
elle ça pose la question du progrès du
progrès technologique
réversibilité elle est palpable
j'ajouterai que le problème il faut
aussi se poser c'est quand on voit une
faute quand une photo est inventée il y
a une mémoire rétinienne on peut malgré
soi être influencé si je vois une photo
par exemple qui ridiculise un personnage
public et puis une deuxième même si on
m'explique après que la photo est un
montage ou une création d'Unia mon
cerveau est marqué par ça c'est presque
irréversible en fait donc c'est très ça
va être ça fait partie des triangles on
peut s'étonner du fait qu'on en discute
très peu on essaye d'en discuter grâce à
vous Thomas
et réseaux sociaux un espace public en
décomposition c'est-à-dire à la fois
merci beaucoup dominer de nous avoir
accompagnés pendant cette heure de
direct dans sa vogue merci à vous les
affranchis à très vite et très belle
soirée à vous soirée documentaire bien
sûr qui commence maintenant avec
Jean-Pierre Gratien à demain
[Musique]